hello everyone and welcome to 2018
candidates tournament with an extremely
interesting game between Vladimir
Kramnik and eleven Iranian now it seems
like Kramnik decided that the the it
doesn't matter who wins the candidates
this is all gonna be about him he keeps
stealing the spotlight with every game
he plays and all the attention is always
on his game and it's it's no different
in this game in this game he he does
have the white pieces and it's both of
them or have three and a half points out
of nine so no one no one is having the
tournament of their lives here but you
know what are you gonna do are you gonna
simply play a nice quiet game and raw or
are you gonna you know go out kicking so
let's see this game and Kramnik opens
the game with E 4 so he as our engine
play d4 against him and allowed kramnik
to go for that Berlin brilliancy it
seems like kramnik is interested in
returning the favor so he goes for we
have E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and
Bishop to c4 Bishop to c5 so the Joko
piano and here Knight to c3 he doesn't
go for the Evans gambit although he
could have I mean Knight to c3
we have Knight to f6 the four Knights
game b3 now and a6 always so useful move
preparing b5 maybe making room for the
bishop on a7 if he decides he doesn't
want to exchange it too early a lot a
lot of useful maneuvers to this a6 move
although you know when when you were
studying from chess books they always
taught you that this was kind of a loss
of a tempo but you know okay nice the d5
Knight captures on d5 Bishop captures
and d6 Bishop to e3 offering an exchange
of bishops Bishop captures have captures
and here are young castles and it's only
move nine and we already exchanged one
pair of knights and one pair of bishops
so it doesn't seem like anything crazy
is about to happen this game but chromic
castles and knights the b8 preparing to
room riemann over the night we are d7 to
f6
we have b4
creating an outpost for the bishop on b3
so it doesn't block the B to pawn nice
to d7 we have Queen to d2 and now c6
Bishop goes to B 3 a 5 now a 3 Knight to
f6 and h3 now not allowing any knight or
Bishop to g4 ideas h6 by Oregon is well
rook a to b 1 and now b5 Queen to c3
attacking the c6 pawn bishop defends it
and now rook to f2 preparing to double
up rooks on the F file Queen to b6 now
eyeing this e3 pawn and you do have to
defend it so rook to e1 and rook F to e8
adding more protection to D pawn maybe
this fall out the deep want to be pushed
in the future as the deep one is rather
weak here Cromley goes 490 to h4 and our
onion pushes c5 and you do have a lot of
options here one of the ideas was
definitely to try the immediate rook
captures on f6 but it's not the best way
to go with white so Cromley goes for the
best idea he goes rook to f1 first he
that was a pro counter and the F file
has Aragon by playing c5 is no longer
attacking d3 pawn so C capture some
before so what do you do here if you
capture if you recap from before you
lose the e3 pawn but this was a chronic
side eeeh
Queen to e1 so giving up one pawn and
now d5 we have a capture some b4 d
captures on e4 and now B captures on an
a5 so here onion can capture with the
rook or capture with the Queen if he
captures with the Queen he's offering to
exchange Queens so obviously that's kind
of releasing the tension but our onion
plays rook captures on a5 and here the
things get a little crazy
chronic plays Knight to g6 and okay
that's a very nice outpost for the night
the pawn on f7 this pain to do to the
bishop on b3 so what do you do here as
black here it took origin a lot of time
to find the idea and it seems like you
could go for a captures on d3 but this
this is so complicated and even even if
you calculate everything you still don't
know where we stand here of course
black-white would go for rook captures
on f6 and after G captures on f6 win to
g3 and now you find a move for black
here you know there are a lot of threats
here
you're the most obvious one being Knight
captures on e5 simply winning winning a
piece here but even after you play
something like rook to a7 defending this
against this threat what what do you
play here and and who is better here
that's the question obviously the
engines evaluation is it's a pretty
equal a slight advantage for black but
this is I don't think this would be
possible for a human to evaluate and
allow himself to get caught in this kind
of a position so after Knight to g6
Ireland was Bishop to e6 immediately you
know nullifies the influence of this
Bishop on b3 so now F captors than g6 is
a threat but of course this allows
Knight captures an e5 so now our known
place it captures on d3 and now comes
finally route captures on f6g captures
on f6 rook captures on f6 so okay this
does ahem in blacks position a bit this
bishop on e6 a spin now it can't move
due to the Queen being on b6 and you
know queen is coming to g3
there are a lot of ideas here the rook
will be able to capture on h6 so Aragon
plays the only precise defensive idea he
plays D 2 and D 2 is a very tricky idea
now of course if you capture the d2 pawn
I mean if you can't capture it you
definitely want to I mean I passed pawn
and d2 that's a very dangerous pawn but
if you capture it then you get rock to a
1 check King moves and now Queen to a5
pretty much forcing you to exchange
Queens you don't want to allow Queen to
e1 so this would be this would be okay
for black but after D - of course
Kramnik doesn't capture it he was Queen
to g3 check and we have King to f8 King
to f8 was the only move but finding it
when you saw this position after Queen
to g3 you
you probably think okay it's it's game
over of course if King to h8 then rock
captures on h6 this is checkmate
if King to h7 it seems like a reasonably
good square but then c4 wins the game
there is no defense against the bishop
to c2 this checks the king he has to
move rook captures on h6 it's game over
so after this Queen to g3 check Ireland
had to find a very nice defensive idea
but he already had to find it when he
played d2 King to f8 here and this
actually allows Knight to d7 check
checking the King for King the Queen you
can't capture the night otherwise rook
captures Queen and b6 so if if gromek
did play this Knight to d7 check then
Aragon had in mind King to e7 and after
the knife captures then comes rook to
a-1 check King moves now comes rope to
h1 check King has the capture now Queen
upon to d1 promoting to a queen king
moves and now King captures on f6 and
now black is again up the exchange and
it's it's questionable if if black could
get out of all all the checks here but
if he could he would definitely not be
worse and it I mean black can only be
better here he like can be worse here so
this was the idea Aragon had when he
played this King to f8 move so chronic
didn't play Knight to d7
although realistically this was his best
shot he played rook to f1 and rook to f1
isn't the most precise move but again
what do you play here as Black Rock to
d8 is simply threatening this upon 2 D 1
seems like seems like the way to go but
our gang goes rock to a7 he wants to
defend the f7 pawn here we have Knight
to g6 check King to g7 and now Knight to
f4 check King moves to h8 and now nice
to h5 and all of a sudden chronic is
threatening Queen to g7 checkmate so
here you can play rock to g8 defending
because Queen to e5 will be deadly so f
6rm
so the rook from a7 is defending g7 we
have night captures on f6 and now look
to a fate as the rook was attacked and
also if the knight moves then rook
captures MF 1 will be deadly
here Queen to f4 now threatening Queen
captures pawn and h6 with Czech followed
by Queen to h7 checkmate and here there
is only one move that our engine can
play that successfully defends this
position for black he played rock to
rock to h7 now of course this defense
dh6 pawn and also you can't grab with
the night because you lose the Queen on
f4 here Queen to e5 was played and now
there are a lot of moves here Aragon
could play unfortunately he chose the
worst move or the worst move possible
for example rook to g7 is fine simply
not alarming and it discoveries blocking
the Queen's x-ray attack to the king but
he played Queen to c7 with the idea of
exchanging rooks and here there are
plenty of ways to win for white but you
know feel free to pause the video here
and find the move for yourselves in the
game I mean I do hope you try and solve
it I will give it a couple of seconds as
usual for those of you who founded
congratulations it's it's not that
difficult to move as crowning this
played pretty fast it's I don't know
what since I'm not watching the official
fee a stream I don't know the times on
the board exactly but I'd say Aragon was
extremely low one time when he played
Queen to c7 and here kramnik plate
Knight to e8 check and it was in this
position that Irina resigned the game
what would follow is if you for example
move the King simply Queen captures
would check Queen blocks now comes rock
captures rook captures and after Knight
to f6 check King moves Queen checks King
moves and now Queen captures an f7 with
check King moves and Queen captures on
h7 this is checkmate but
a lot of other interesting lines are
possible for example if if you don't
block with kinked g8 you could also go
up to have six blocking but if rook to
f6
then again you simply play queen captors
on f6 Queen blocks and now Knight
captures on g7 simply no defense for
black here rock captures now Queen
captures here with Czech you block or
you move the King and Bishop captures
only six and now rope to f8 Bishop
blocks and rook actress Angie 8 this is
checkmate
but Aragon wasn't interested as soon as
chronic play Knight to 8 I'm pretty sure
he instantly resigned but yeah if any of
you caught the live stream and know
anything about the situation on the
clocks do share in the comments and
especially if you've seen the interviews
after the game as kramnik as you all
know it became such a legend of the
after game interviews so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I still
don't have the standings as there are
some games still being played at the
Fabiano mama D our game is still being
played but I think I will show that game
as well and then we'll deliver the
standings so after this game chronic is
in on four and a half out of ten so
tomorrow is playing Fabiano maybe he can
do some damage with his new a newly
acquired pirate style as well who knows
we'll just have to wait and see so yeah
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here and thank you for watching
and I will see you soon I probably would
another game from the candidates thank
you all